mieux vaut laisser vos branches du
mouvement réflexe toujours là ça va et
vients rêvée pour adultes eux de voir on
va rouler mais l'objectif ultime de ces
soignants au grand coeur sauver des vies
bienvenue en fait
à la zone sont des soins intensifs comme
vous voyez c'est placardées un peu
partout pour être sûr que personne ne
rendent de manière non prévus elle
s'appelle cathy jennifer l'insee
geneviève c'est soignante accepte de
nous donner accès à leur quotidien
donc les lieux physiques qui si l'on
voit qu'on a deux ans dans la zone
chaude ou contaminés si on veut le prêt
des vitres des patients donc nous ça
nous permettre de se déplacer dans ce
cas qui dorlote d'une chambre à l'eau en
changeant nos gars mais en gardant le
reste de l'équipement de protection fait
dans cette zone la personne n'y aura
qu'une personne avec des gars est bien
protégé sauver des vies mais d'abord se
protéger l'aco ville et virulente tout
le monde qu'on s'y dit à un moment ou à
un autre mais qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
le t on et yaggeurs et qu'est ce qui se
passe on sauve sans courant non on est
là faut faut combattre ce à date ça se
passe bien personne dans notre
département s'est contaminé en aucune
éclosion sont attentifs ici on est bien
fiers de ça donc on continue comme ça
les procédures sont strictes et
exigeante
l'ensemble des méthodes de travail a été
chamboulé par la coved 19 on évite les
allers retours dans les chambres une
infirmière demeurent à l'extérieur
il soutient ceux qui sont au chevet des
patients par les images on veut vous
démontrer c'est quoi notre travail
mettez le but et peuvent se plaindre
dire que mon succès dont difficile oui
c'est difficile mais on lem qui ont
pendant tout ce quand même à tout ce
pion qui l'ont encore plus difficile que
nous dans tous sont quand même là ici on
est impatient ça fait vingt-cinq jours
qui est avec nous s'apprête à lever au
fauteuil le mafieux était sous
respirateur le depuis son arrivée il ya
présentement une trachéotomie monsieur
est encore
malgré tout ces journées très malade
déjà 25 jours aux soins intensifs une
situation qui n'a malheureusement rien
d'exceptionnel pour les patients
atteints de lakovic 19
plusieurs sont sous respirateur pendant
des jours et certains sont placés en
position ventrale pour améliorer leur
oxygénation bon donc on s'apprête à
tourner le patient ici en ventre comme
vous voyez on est beaucoup de
partenaires
chacune de personnes à sa taille dans la
paille une altitude germea préposés de
chaque côté s'occupe de grand père est
vraiment que je fais que tout est
sécuritaire une manoeuvre délicate il
faut sept personnes pour tourner le
patient une technique qui peut prendre
jusqu'à une trentaine de minutes les
soins des patients atteints de colite 19
demande plus de temps et de personnel
par exemple déplacer un patient en vue
d'un examen exige toute une gymnastique
le patient est instable il fait 40.5 de
fièvre qu'on se prépare à l'otago pour
voir qu'est ce qui se passe
donc on voit que quelqu'un à l'avant qui
ouvre les portes à l'infirmière le
préposé li na lo qui hélas est quelqu un
à l'arrière qui l'avait ce qui peut être
contaminée ce qu'ils ont touché dans
l'ascenseur aussi repassé derrière tout
nettoyé pendant qu'une bonne partie de
l'équipe est occupée auprès de ce malade
de nouveaux patients continuent d'être
ennemis comment vous respirez pas bien
pourquoi pas là ok on va vous installer
dans votre lit et là vous allez mieux
respirer après ago 1 2 3 go jusqu'à
maintenant 610 patients malades de l'aco
vides ont été hospitalisés ici à
l'enfant jésus dont 90 aux soins
intensifs bonjour monsieur bouchard
vous êtes sur votre départ on pouvait
pas manquer l'occasion de souligner
votre anniversaire
bon mais puis il y a ceux qui vont assez
bien pour quitter les soins on a tous
deux signés personnel jour soit on
faisait acheter un petit gâteau nous ça
représente beaucoup pour nous autres
bobos vous l'amener avec vous c'est
certain on a traversé sa demande en sens
inverse que vous devez prendre mon pc
vos bonbons qui nous encouragent nous a
continué parce que l'écho
continu-continu fois le monsieur était
contents on était content hôtels et
sourire les larmes
c'est du bonheur pour nous la proportion
victoire versus défaite tu peux pas vous
le dire je le sais pas mais
moitié-moitié pas parce que c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est avec vous monsieur on vous
accompagne
mais tous n'ont pas la chance de pouvoir
dire merci à ce jour à l'enfant jésus
144 patients ont été emportés par la
maladie
la prostitution avec la famille du
patient et selon les dernières volontés
de monsieur nous avons
décidé de
se diriger vers des soins de confort et
dans le contexte actuel c'est pas
toujours évident pour les familles de se
présenter venir accompagner leurs
proches
donc si nous en tant qu'infirmier qui
devant
[Musique]
accomplir cette tâche d'accompagner nos
patients une semaine le moment donné on
en a perdu 4,5 dans un seul bloc le puy
s'est dit pas ça qui nous a tous touchés
en fin de la semaine en tête haute et
motifs on pleurait beaucoup on s'attache
veut pas pu souvent c'est quand on
serait en même temps soit une fin de vie
ça c'est plus difficile parce que sinon
vraiment qu'ils vont venir comme fermer
le respirateur exemple pour vraiment
confirmer que ces derniers effectuent ce
savine chercher au soutien on s'attache
aussi dans certains continuent mais avec
la colline de face des soins de confort
l'eau sans la famille aux côteries
littéralement pour accompagner la
personne dans ce dernier moment que
finalement ça soit nous qui prennent en
main du patient aura ce dernier moment
ses yeux ces troubles
les patients atteints de la coved 19 ont
passé en moyenne neuf jours aux soins
intensifs
l'absence des familles tenu à l'écart en
raison des dangers liés au virus a
contribué à resserrer les liens
soignants patients et ils étaient plus
agitée il était très réveillés
l'extérieur près le temps de discuter
avec lui de vraiment de le rassurer
aussi on a fini par comprendre malgré le
tube qui désiraient parler à sa femme
fait présentement et stéphanie tient le
téléphone en fait à son oreille pour
qu'ils puissent entendre sa femme mais
leur assurer les équipes médicales sont
aussi plus soudés que jamais on est
devant la même vague qui nous arrive
dessus on est tout le composteur qui en
arrière de nouba c'est nos familles et
nos amis c'est la population générale
c'est des gens que je connaîtrais
peut-être jamais mais que quand même
je veux protéger tous fait le fait que
ont fait rempart face à son ensemble ça
crée un sentiment de solidarité une
bonne chose parce que le travail est
aussi plus demandant qu avant la
pandémie qui porte avec le collier
c'est qu'on a des filles des défis
supplémentaires enfin que soignant c'est
difficile pour nos équipes aussi de
passer plusieurs minutes plusieurs
heures dans une chambre on est marqué au
niveau du front que le viseur on est
marqué au niveau du visage avec le n95
on au chaud donc c'est sûr que c'est
très bruyant sur l'environnement hostile
c'est pas un environnement qui est
plaisant à travailler
[Musique]
oui c'est un peu inhumain c'est vrai
mais c'est la copie qui est inhumaine
cpo c'est pas mon traitement s'est passé
parce qu'on fait qui est une mince c'est
la maladie et le nombre de patients
malades hospitalisés est à la hausse
ils sont 96 dont huit aux soins
intensifs ce monsieur est un des 24
heures du mans t on un tube en août à
8h15 ce matin aussi leur qu'elle est
moins bien
c'est un petit ça se passe un petit peu
moins bien dans les hôpitaux
présentement j'ai vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de spécialisation et
aux soins intensifs l'eau sa route
beaucoup en un tube c'est un vrai look
malheureusement ici on espère être en
nombre suffisant pour répondre aux
besoins de la population
les chambres sont pleines de passion la
moyenne d'âge ici des patients et entre
60 et 75 ans environ et en a qui vont
dire que c'est vieux nous on trouve pas
un il y en a qui prennent leur retraite
à 60 65 ans fait que lyon on trouve
qu'ils y ont droit de vivre après ces
gens-là y ont des enfants des enfants
ont le droit de les voir grandir
évidemment elle s'inquiète de voir
certains citoyens banaliser la maladie
tout le monde peut avoir la copie de
tout le monde parle des séquelles
dessous parce qu'on veut vraiment risqué
ce et c'est ça que moi je travaille à
noyelles fait que ce soit quelqu'un je
veux finir la saison
moi je vais te contentes de pouvoir
appeler mon par maman ma famille mais à
l'inversé ceux qui vivent à l'hôpital
les patients belges présentes que cette
journée leur famille aux autres vont
attendre l'appel du médecin pour
justement avoir des nouvelles
ou peut-être un zoom voient leur est
offert pour voir leurs membres de
famille hospitalisée sous respirateur
mettez profiter profiter des appels
profiter dès qu'on fait des vidéos c'est
profiter de votre famille en forme parce
qu'un fou rendu à l'hôpital c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile mais
malgré les nombreux écueils liés au
travail en tant que co vide
tous gardent le cap tout faire pour
soigner ces patients que le virus a
terrassé en studio ergo aussi prendre la
réadaptation que la passion et la soie
sur le bord du lit
on voit que le patient obligions pour la
première fois on est toujours content
l'instant le camp qu'on voit les
premiers signes d'un patient qui
s'éveille
c'est notre ses notes tcd petite
victoire pour nous ça nous fait chaud
qu'un 53 patients qui ont été
hospitalisés ici sont guéris pierre dion
l2 il est de retour chez lui
même chose pour d'en thibaud à 39 ans il
a passé deux semaines ou soins intensifs
ici ghislaine bussières radio canada
québec
[Musique]